this week we've got a Canada shark tank
at Walmart Gamecock Walmart game or gang
game well my game that's our last story
my game I like King I like Shark Tank I
do - that's one of my favorite shows but
that's number two right so let's go to
number one number one is yay Canada yay
did you guys hear the entire country of
Canada has now legalized marijuana ah we
heard that was going to happen when we
were in Canada they always got a one-up
us always [ __ ] man like a lot of their
country people don't live in it so like
there's like people who live on this
side and people live on this side and
there's a whole vast expanse of nowhere
that's true their population is like a
nugget compared to life our country
everyone has to vote and all of the
country there's people living in all
parts yeah and they're all like similar
in thinking so it's not as different as
us yeah cuz the coastal states tend to
be the same voting wise and if you look
at Canada they're just the coastal like
basically there's like being Coover and
then Toronto and Montreal
that's so dear friend so now the police
they've been tweeting out these like
meme sort of things so for example this
one it says asking what to do with your
frozen meat during a power outage is not
in 911
smelling weed coming from your
neighbor's home isn't either cannabis is
no longer a legal on October 17 2018
consumption will be allowed for anyone
19 years and older do not call police
for this oh I'm gonna call my mom and
I'm gonna rub it in her face
October 16th must be like Christmas Eve
oh yeah I mean it's a new day I'll be
like remember how you told me that weed
is so bad like cocaine and that's gonna
make people go crazy well guess what
Canada just made it legalized and she's
like yeah but I still think all that
[ __ ] I know
oh don't think all that that's why
they're making these Me's or tweeting
about it's like to like change the
perception now yeah weed is not illegal
don't bother us the cops but you know it
is plastic straws don't you dare of a
plectrum do it you [ __ ] you are
killing wildlife you get him out of here
but weed is okay all right next one says
asking pictures I think police to call
your friend because you're out of
minutes is not a 9-1-1 call calling
about your neighbors pot plant isn't
either
last one here asking for directions
because you're lost is not a 9-1-1 call
reporting an adult smoking a joint isn't
either
i wonder if people are gonna just
massively grow in canada and then just
ship it over to america now they have up
to four plants but for us it's fine
poking a joint isn't illegal cuz here
we're a Cal in California you're still
not allowed to just light up like honest
I'm pretty sure you can't just light up
on yeah I think is lost I think I still
have to respect the same like cigarette
no no no yeah cigarette laws so anywhere
cigarettes can be smoked in Canada at
least I'm not sure about here but in
Canada you can so cuz here when I got
legalized there was this di DUI
checkpoint and we were like oh [ __ ] you
know like we had a drink well how long
ago was that that was like two hours ago
okay I think we're good we're like we're
fine and we're like oh [ __ ] you know are
they gonna it's always scary going
through a DUI checkpoint and the cop
like pulls I was like flashlight and he
looks like he puts shines into my eyes
and he's like have you guys been smoking
marijuana tonight alright okay so just
so you know even though marijuana is
legal you are not allowed to smoke and
drive yeah you're in Canada finish your
beer and get the [ __ ] on out here yeah
that's the only place where you they're
not you're not allowed to smoke to smoke
marijuana where cigarettes are allowed
which is in the vehicle you can't do
that
Oh cigarettes you can't smoke in the
vehicle either no no my good you can
that's the only place that doesn't have
the same lock okay dude they should pull
over everybody who's driving like 15
miles an hour in a 50 mile an hour
Ruthann in a blasting reggae yeah and
they're driving a VW bus everyone in
Santa Barbara
they're always I always just start
pulling those people over get them off
the road anyway because it's only they
always clog everything up oh they're the
ones that cause the trap yeah they are
I love CBD products yes master
dude that CBD the lotion you got is
tight I'm kind of like and it was like a
miracle bitter about this because you
know why couldn't we be legal when I was
smoking all day every day like why is it
guys now get over it no it's not fair
because I don't even smoke anymore well
that's like the same [ __ ] is like us
getting mad that we didn't have the same
smart phones we have now than we were
but that's different it's not legal like
you I feel bad for all the people that
got locked up in jail that's what I'm
saying yeah those people that's for sure
they're getting rid of a lot of I forgot
what it's called nonviolent drug
offenders yeah especially marijuana like
lot of states but they should they
should have always done that
getting them out of jail I actually
think the the chemical [ __ ] like meth
and stuff like that we need to keep
those criminalized oh absolutely yeah
because there's so much fun
there's so many more bums now that are
just [ __ ] high and crazy is it worse
when it's illegal no because those drugs
actually make people like crazy in like
you know by oh yeah violin and stuff
where's marijuana like it relaxes you
yeah yeah yeah yeah marijuana alcohol is
a depressant I mean that one people get
violent too it's like I guess there
would be a strong argument for you to
kill you thank you but that's why you
can't have both in my opinion like it's
like keep meth illegal but alcohol
illegal I'm like I don't know man well
alcohol just has always been legal and
so when they try to do that during the
Prohibition there was it was just bad no
I know there's wind up like crazy and
then violence went up like for you the
mob was made no so you couldn't put the
toothpaste back in the and the tube but
meth the toothpaste is still in the tube
we don't have to take it out yeah yeah
it's like I think the rule of thumb is
the slower the death from this substance
keep that legal
cigarettes alcohol weed that's legal and
it doesn't make people crazy yeah cuz
meth like my friend gotta this is a
message and she started stealing from me
she stole all kinds of yeah she needs
money for math yeah exactly but like
I've never had my drunk friend do that
you know yeah they just want to fight
like crazy there's the new [ __ ] like the
[ __ ] fentanyl like people think that
they're like X they're zombies and [ __ ]
that one's scary yeah everybody's
overdose we're people doing that with
bath salts a couple years ago yeah I
think that is the Fed oh it is there's
something about wearing a shirt that
says legalized meth that I am pretty for
I don't know idea of being like deal man
we gotta legalize math come on guys I'm
pretty into it actually what do you guys
think about codeine is that role but
dozen yeah that's tough some fair
prescription stuff
Oh rappers drinking was frightened oh my
god and like they get really like high
mm-hm I tried it before
I never it felt like ecstasy that's all
please I don't know what that is cuz I
tried that one owes me do you think
ecstasy should be like it should be
legal yeah DMA should be legal well they
just approved it for like medical
treatment and oh yeah they're for people
like like depression yeah yes of your
depression is any type of drug that gets
you to [ __ ] bite another human being
in the fairway scratch all of your skin
off yeah that should not be legal or
guide your own eye out I just love CBD
products man they're [ __ ] fantastic
like if I had no cuz I'm so injury prone
like I've had so many injuries over like
it's just from basketball sport students
to be sure just walking in general like
I've had like I fractured both my ankles
I tore my ACL on my right knee I have
like patellar tendon tendinitis in my
left knee now and I told my labrum my
right shoulder so this is like stuff
that you have to deal with all the
[ __ ] time and I'd like a [ __ ] up
like rib to from the Tesla car accident
so like I haven't been able to find
anything to help me like [ __ ] relax
and feel good [ __ ] CBD creams helps
out a lot
been like way more chill now recently I
was like you're not in pain anymore so
you're not so like yeah I'm not so uh
yeah it helps out a lot though like it's
pretty [ __ ] good man like I just I'm
kind of like upset that it took this
long for that to happen you know the bat
on your back
Oh uses the CBD cream there's a topical
cream like how do you how do you get
reached there oh oh [ __ ]
wow you're flexible that's way flexible
I can't do that I can only do it with
this arm I can't do it I can't read I'm
too Bob yeah but not this hands like
nope bye [ __ ] yeah moving on to the
next story - Bob
so speaking of Canada this takes place
in Toronto this dude entered a Ripley's
Aquarium and jumped into the shark tank
and swam naked with the Charmin Ripley's
Believe It or Not the power of meth here
you go
legalized meth I hold baby I hope he
bites his [ __ ] dick bitter I think
that's what he wants the sharks on
Friday October 12th guests at Ripley's
aquariums Friday night jazz event he's
just walking around or pick up nobody
cared that's not well there Trenton
attention why do we have to arrest him
he's having so much fun I think live in
his free life well I mean the arrest was
mainly because about two hours before
that he got into this fistfight with
some dude and so he got arrested this
was in Canada this guy is not Canadian I
know also - cuz he flashed a bunch of
children off so he got in a fistfight at
the aquarium and then he decided to jump
in and swim with sharks that was his
resolve like ma'am so angry they were
probably arguing about the fact they
says I bet you had a jump of that naked
oh yeah exactly
watch this looking back dive
that is that is meth like behavior size
37 year old named David yeah what I like
about this guy - is he's a grown man
doing this you like that it's it's a lot
funnier will do were there drugs
involved at all do we know not that I
know of
that's too bad well Canada has to
protect the reputation so even if there
were they'd be like we don't know we
would there's an American tourist big
just legalized marijuana but but that's
not a drug now because it's legal okay
well I mean tobacco and alcohol they're
still and even like aspirin nope nothing
is a drug take a pee no no no is legal
not a drug sugar check anything that you
give me addicted that's how the opioid
crisis is is happening because people
are getting prescribed these drugs that
have opioids in them and then oh you
don't getting addicted to them I just
found out that people are dying off of
opioids like tens of thousands right
every year yeah guess how many people
die from like hard drugs like what hard
drugs like cocaine and all that [ __ ]
found a few hundred just a couple
thousand hmm you gotta look it up look
up at the statistics in marijuana it's
drastically yeah [ __ ] different so
like meth cocaine all the [ __ ] all that
combined is like nothing compared to
opioid are you lumping heroin in there
because heroin isn't nope is but uh it's
not prescription opioid oh yeah yeah
yeah all the prescription prescription
opioid yeah that like abusing those
painkillers whatever that [ __ ] is people
are dying why are they still doing that
cuz you know how food
that's what I'm saying so like I know
that it's all a money thing right but
then if these people are dying and
they're losing their customers dude
that's like when Rosina these we need
more people that's like when Roseanne
tweeted that [ __ ] and then the [ __ ]
ambien company was like yeah racism
isn't a side effect an ambien I'm like
you guys are [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] dude
like the fact that a pharmaceutical
company who pushes people using their
product and needs people using their
product like is clowning on somebody who
used their product like it had bad a bad
well they just wanted to disavow but I
know but I just think that that that was
creepy to me and weird yeah I mean also
too it's kind of weirdly I don't know
why ambien will come out of like that
first of all like ambien has been known
to [ __ ] people up yeah exactly yeah like
I guess I'm not sure if it's like
alcohol mixed with ambien but it's like
because when I was you know I have
trouble sleeping all the [ __ ] time
I never took ambien because I was
looking up like melatonin a me and
whatever could help you go to sleep but
ambien had like stuff where there's been
multiple cases where people take that
with something else
and it made them freak the [ __ ] out like
they would wake up but make it somewhere
or they would be [ __ ] like doing like
crazy zombie [ __ ] or some [ __ ] so that's
like legit and ambien issue but then
Andy and talk to your friend like that's
not a side if I could use an amp you
know I'm saying yeah it's like dude
negative side effects really fast man
maybe damn straight
exactly but I would never take ambien
though [ __ ] the pharmaceuticals exactly
yeah I know so many people just directly
that have passed away from that dude
we're over diagnosing the [ __ ] out of
everything - have you seen have you
noticed that we're it's like everything
is some new psychological thing and now
you need a restless leg syndrome yeah
right leg syndrome
yeah
your fake ass disease it's not fake I'm
just doing it just now I heard it was a
fake ass disease it's a fake ass do I
suffer from it you make it fun of me to
2018 that's a disorder bro you know what
though what the real racket though is
now people are convinced that if they
have anxiety depression all these things
that they just will live with it for the
rest of their lives and it's just really
a perception shift but you can't tell
them that because they know you don't
know how serious serious it is you know
they want these people to go get therapy
never ending lifelong therapy and they
want them to be on [ __ ] drugs that's
true dude they prescribed for everything
yeah and then but then people that are
experienced it will defend it to the
[ __ ] T if you say that you can
actually do it with a procession of
perception shift some people with the
chemical things some people it's more
psychological I think it depends because
like with a chemical imbalance you can't
psychologically change it right like you
need a little bit of drugs to balance it
but that's a very small minority it is a
very small we're born with yeah
like in his case like he had Graves
disease right which drove him into
depression because of the chemical
reaction that he had yeah most people
you can you can do psychology like you
more like less people don't want to hear
like hey why don't you try changing your
perspective because they think that
you're minimizing what they're going on
right which I'm not at all like you're
invalidating the yeah yeah what I'm
trying to say is go to better help calm
slash Steve green hey yourself somehow I
actually use better help and I'm not
sponsored by them but I like I like them
well that's what I'm saying cuz we we
did we did this video and I was
mentioned in that too cuz because I got
sponsored by better help and I used it
first before I you know just to test it
out and it was great yeah and I had a
bunch of people tell me they've been
using it and they liked it so I was a
little confused why people hated it so
much I guess some people had bad
experience yeah yeah but there are
people who actually like this totally
I was like yo what the [ __ ] is everybody
mad at this company cuz I still don't
get it
yeah well I love how people are like
detectiving the thing were they're like
oh we found in the fine print it says
better help doesn't actually have to
help you that's psychology bro yeah you
go to a psychologist it's like hey we
don't know if we can help you or not
like that the whole [ __ ] game yeah
because it's really up to the person to
want to change and believe and think and
build those new habits into those well
sometimes they don't know how to and
that's why you need to see a
professional and like go to a
psychologist to like dig up those roots
because sometimes you just like most
people I think don't know how to solve
their own issues without a professional
100% but it's up to them to do put in
the work - yes yeah it's like just cuz
you come into karate class doesn't mean
you're gonna be an awesome karate yeah
exactly
alright guys last story which is nothing
at all completely just totally unrelated
to what we're talking about Walmart has
this new there's a sponsor one game it's
not father TIFF no no cuz it's about the
game yeah third with time and true the
clothing line it's a great clothing line
anyway this iPhone game here so there's
coming helices what he's jealous I'm
jealous I'm too I want to be sponsored
by their sports section and their food
aisles monster by legalized math comm
they're mini fridges iPhone game is I'm
trying to my job here work out Walmart
yes it's a work this looks like a
first-person shooter game they're saying
that this is like legit like what it
feels like to work in retail a lot of
people are saying like you know you have
your manager telling you what to do and
like stalking and then there's spills
you need to clean up no no no this is
not real retail what they need is a
rabid crackhead running in biting people
and then they need like like a like a
senior citizen taking a [ __ ] in the
middle of the aisle thinking that it's a
bathroom they need a mom coming in
yelling because they put a quarter in
the little jiggly machine outside for
their kid and
it's not working and they need their
money back right now thinking I gotta go
yeah they also had like to crack it's
[ __ ] turn the corner we need
teenagers stealing and making a YouTube
video in there we need we need people in
the return section trying to return
items that they never bought from the
store and get store credit
I can't even seen when they won't do it
oh I love that [ __ ] man we'd be like hey
I bought these necklaces from here and
they're not real gold so I'll just take
the other cash back thank you and it's
like people going to the field by this
man when you people go into the self
checkout line and then like they try to
steal like half of the items that's some
real Walmart [ __ ] right there is that in
the game this game is called spark city
I don't know if that's a [ __ ] but
they're saying that you're able to like
maximise on shelf customer availability
and sales while keeping your area clean
fast and friendly that's like so there's
so many waitressing games like this and
I've played them just like like diner -
when I get like it's like no it's like
it's exactly like working out at a
restaurant we're like you have to
fulfill these orders and you have to get
everyone's order on time and then the
customers start getting mad and all set
and I don't know why I play them because
my whole thing is like I never want to
go back to waitressing because it's
exactly like that
but for some reason when I'm stressed
out with like YouTube or editing I'll
play these games because it's like
familiarity familiar torture and I'm
like oh I know I can handle it and when
I beat them I'm like yeah I'm a [ __ ]
good waitress I know how you feel I know
how you feel because that's I feel when
I play GTA yeah okay wait what do you
mean you're one of those [ __ ] who
like bowls and [ __ ] you know like shoot
no no no I like doing jobs yeah doing
jobs feeling like he's saying he used to
do this yeah like a pillar of the
community again you know like just yeah
yeah just I guess because you know
YouTube is so like this all the time and
I'm like I don't know what I'm doing and
then I'm like oh I know how to waitress
even though he sucks and it's super
stressful I know what I'm doing
[Music]
[Music]